salut et merci de votre fidélité à ce
rendez vous aujourd'hui je vous propose
de découvrir le parcours inspirant d'un
vos clients il s'appelle cédric de
bulles et vit en colombie où le dirige
un grand hôtel on parle de retrouver
tout de suite à bogota salut cédric
c'est un plaisir de te rencontrer tu à
bogota en colombie c'est ça en colombie
3-1 alors à parler de la colombie tout à
leuhan tu nous expliquera ce qu'il ya de
beau à voir là bas mais avant on va
s'intéresser à ton parcours qui est
vraiment un parcours d'excellence
aujourd'hui tu travailles pour une
grande chaîne d'hôtels qui existent
mondialement dans le monde l'une des
plus grandes d'ailleurs pour ne pas la
citer
on a une petite idée comment est-ce
qu'un blocs l'inra s'est retrouvé à
faire le tour du monde à travailler dans
un hôtel aussi précisé aujourd'hui thé
directeur d'hôtel en plus un travail à
barcelone mais non ça fait vraiment
rêver les destinations dont ils pensent
vraiment les fondations de vacances
comment ça s'est passé et ça commençait
en martinique déjà fait une école
hôtelière ou quelque chose comme ça
comment tu t'es retrouvé dans don dans
ce milieu là je voulais faire un don de
sang je suis parti bien vous êtes une
série le mans et j'ai pas du tout
évident mais ça donc j'ai cherché une
reconversion qui permet de mettre de
retour des travailleuses antique et donc
j'ai fait une maîtrise en gestion
hôtelière et j'ai commencé à travailler
tout de suite prouvé que donne à paris
de la jeu j'ai commencé à sillonner le
monde entier on va s'intéresser à la
colombie est aujourd'hui
particulièrement ces beaux visiblement
la colombie des retours que j'ai eu des
personnes qui ont eu la chance de
visiter apparemment c'est magnifique
répétez l'agréable surprise je
connaissais déjà parce que je voyage est
pour eux pour le business qu'on doit
dire que j'ai pas cours à sa autres et
beaucoup clients ici mais devenir des
vrais signes amis savaient vraiment les
gens sont extraordinaires elle payait
très bien
exploit sur les et puis on pense
beaucoup à la colombie dix à vingt ans a
beaucoup changé
moi j'ai complètement amoureux de ce
pays vraiment j'aime beaucoup les gens
sont extraordinaires il ya une forte une
culture très fort les gens sont très
hospitaliers et effet beaucoup
d'adversité ya des partis qui me
rappelle beaucoup la caraïbe de la
carthagène
c'est la capitale de la grande vie avec
sept millions d'habitants
c'est vraiment payé que par contre se
porte l'industrie hôtelière en ce moment
qui j'imagine ou en colombie aussi doit
être frappé par les événements liés aux
kovy 19 comment ça se passe chez vous
c'est un peu difficile enfin moi je gère
aussi cédé à carthage et les deux autres
qui sont fermés depuis deux mois les
aéroports sont fermés
on dépend vraiment des aéroports dans
l'incertitude
ils sont en train de parler de rouvrir
les aéroports bon écoute en tout cas
soit soient prudentes ont coûté bien
évidemment la colombie ce n'est qu'une
étape visiblement pas ce que tu aime
voyager après tout ce que tu as fait et
malgré l'amour de la colombie je crois
tu vas bouger encore bien tôt c'est tout
à fait j'ai donné un prochain projet au
projet d'entente sur l'asie je fais pas
encore donné la destination parce que
c'est pas officiellement mais
certainement fin où je vais partir sur
un gros projet ce qu'on appelle
reconversion en soit sur une grosse
destinations en asie on est on est
vraiment admiratif de ton parcours
on a beaucoup de jeunes en martinique
qui rêverait un peut-être d'avoir cette
vie que tu as de voyages et de diriger
des hôtels d'avoir des postes à
responsabilité à un conseil peut être
pendant ces jeunes martiniquais prospère
est de règle est qu'il faut rêver en
grand
faux pas il faut pas se mettre de
limites on a tendance à se mettre des
barrières naturellement bon nombre d'os
et le styrène animix qu à l égalité pour
moi ya pas de limite travaille dur temps
pour m en gros on peut se donner des
opportunités pour personne que les
choses avaient et après quand on
travaille dur et j'ai toujours dit que
le martiniquais je pense un petit plus
pour l'hôtellerie notre façon d'être
avec voilà j'attends d'eux
d'avoir le prochain directeur général 20
petits mickeys de ses quais les autres
syndicats qui connaît ses carrières donc
grosse fierté
on a eu l'occasion d'avoir un
martiniquais bonnes tes concurrents mais
il est très très loin lui il était du
côté de dubaï je crois et qui nous
disait c'est vrai que nous en martinique
on a cet avantage d'avoir un sourire
spontané un contact facile avec les gens
qu'on n'a pas toujours partout ailleurs
dans le monde par rapport aux cultures
et qu'on a une culture qui est très
accueillant très souriante très proche
de l'autre et que ça en hôtellerie ça
pouvait être un petit plus qui fait la
différence surtout quand on travaille
dans l'hôtellerie de luxe haut de gamme
ou vraiment le sourire qu'on tousse et
on fait encore plus attention à ces
petits détails on a des idées on a des
qualités qui peuvent nous permettre de
briller dans ce secteur là des projets
de la compagnie canton beaucoup de
collègues avec qui j'ai travaillé quand
il parle de cd qui parle des sourires et
parler personne joviale une personne
très people comme on dit avant d'être
démentie ni quémandeurs des gens très
accessible et très joyeux très heureux
et surtout quand on gère les équipes
c'est vrai qu'on puisse pour moi bon en
tout cas on est ravi d'avoir fait ta
connaissance aujourd'hui on attend d'en
savoir un peu plus sur la prochaine
destination
mais à mon avis ça va être très très
bien aussi d'être plein de bonnes choses
à toi merci beaucoup continuent à être
prudents du côté de la colombie continue
bien évidemment ton très très beau
parcours qui est une source
d'inspiration pour nos jeunes et puis
pour nous également
j'espère que tu seras breton du côté du
vauclin de temps en temps tu rentres à
la maison quand même des ressources et
tous les ans je rentre au pays c'est bon
on salue en tout cas toute la famille
une bulle c'est ça du côté du vauclin
merci beaucoup cédric merci pour tout
merci à toi à très bientôt
voilà encore une fois de plus un
parcours très très inspirant une fois de
plus sur la première celui de cédric nul
comme quoi où et un veau aussi qui ont
regardé cette émission qui avait
peut-être des rêves des projets les
envies il faut juste se donner les
moyens de les vivre merci nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve très vite quand la
première vie
[Musique]